opération molokaï à répétition blocage
de certains axes phares de l'île comme
la sahara où le port maritime par
exemple des kilomètres d'embouteillage
absence de transports en commun depuis
le début du mouvement de grève des
salariés de la cft eu de nombreuses
entreprises sont dans la douleur
olivier mosset patron d'un magasin bio
installé à la zone de la jambe est il
est souvent concernés par les barrages
depuis le début du mouvement
le chiffre d'affaires de son magasin est
en baisse de 50% lors des jours de
blocage dans le secteur la perte peut
atteindre 80 % ce sont surtout les
petites entreprises qui vont subir les
conséquences de tels mouvements
on se retrouve démuni zh donc ça nous
pénalise nos entreprises antillaises
on sort en tout il y en août âgées en
difficulté même à se poser des questions
par rapport aux perspectives de
l'entreprise même à la pérennité de
l'entreprise fermeture des licenciements
ce sont les conséquences qui sont à
venir
conséquence également sur l'activité de
cet artisan on peut passer aucune essai
c'est durant sur les routes tous les
jours sirigu ce taux se déplace de
chantier en chantier pour des
prestations dans le btp la semaine
dernière les opérations molokaï ont
perturbé ses déplacements est ralentie
de nombreux chantiers conséquence 1500
euros de moins sur son chiffre
d'affaires en une semaine
la circulation était difficile parce que
j'ai essayé de faire tout les petits
axes et c'était tout le temps bloqué
j'ai pas pu faire ses prestations aux
mêmes ce que j'ai pu faire il me fallait
déposer la voiture effet à quelques
kilomètres à pied c'est le conflit
social est un coup dur pour les patrons
des petites et moyennes entreprises
ils se disent prise en otage surtout en
cette période de l'année
c'est un vrai ras-le-bol je me fais
porte parole de tous ces chefs
d'entreprise qui se bat tous les jours
pour garder leurs activités surtout au
niveau des petites et moyennes
entreprises en armes à des restaurants
qui sont fermés c'est que nous quand
même une période estivale où on arrive à
rattraper un petit peu le chiffre
d'affaires ou les bénéfices qu'on peut
faire sur l'année c'est inadmissible on
se retrouve avec des entreprises qui
n'ont strictement rien à voir avec les
débats de ce conflit et qui se
retrouvent pénalisés complètement par
des méthodes qui ne sont pas acceptables
aujourd'hui face à cette grève de
nombreux commerçants disent se sentir
impuissant
ils attendent tous la fin du conflit